- The disproportional reason so
many people in here will not
win, let's just get right to
the chase, the disproportionate
reason that most people in this
room will not win is actually
not the hard work which is what
I'm gonna talk about probably
for next 45 minutes.
It's your lack of patience.
(applause)
For some unknown
reason when people go into
ventures like this and other
things they somehow miraculously
think it's going to
happen in five minutes.
That you're the one person in
the world, whatever you guys
call your big club and put
posters of each other up on you
think you're going to be in that
circle in five minutes for some
reason 'cause you're the most
charismatic, you figured out
some weird system,
you've got it.
And the lack of patience is
what hurts so many people.
From 22 to 30 years old
for eight years in my
20s I worked 15 hours a day,
seven days a week in my
dad's liquor store.
Today, with all things that have
happened to me, I get emails on
Facebook from friends I went to
high school with often starting
with, "Gary, you're so lucky."
I reply to every
single one of them.
All of them with the reply
of an opening line first,
"Jan, great to see you again.
You look great.
"Kid's super cute.
"P.S. I am super not lucky.
"Let me remind you, Rick,
remember when we graduated
"college and you went to the
Jersey Shore every weekend and
"hooked up with
chicks and drank beer.
"I worked."
(upbeat music)